One day, a cat hiked on a mountain.
When he reached the peak, he met a fox.
They began talking about how they get away from their enemies.
"I am very smart. I have billions of ideas."
"I can carve a tiny hole in a tree and then climb in," the fox said.
He added, "I have a lot of friends."
"If I am in trouble, I can call them to lend their help."
"I can escape an entire army if I have to!"
Then the fox asked, "What are your potential plans?"
The cat said, "I have only one plan."
The fox said, "I hope you have good fortune then!"
"Do you want me to be your tutor? I can teach you many things."
The cat said, "I guarantee that my plan works every time."
"We can quit talking about it."
Soon, they saw a group of wolves.
It was an emergency.
The cat quickly used her plan.
She ran up a tree.
The fox could not decide which plan to use.
"What should my initial move be?"
"Should I consult my friends?"
The fox felt intense anxiety.
All he could do was spin in a circle.
The wolves caught the fox.
The cat was full of pride.
This is proof that having a good plan...
...is better than having many bad plans.